- This is definitely the longest I've ever
touched my nipple in front of a camera.
But not by much.
(playful music)
- They look beautiful,
I'm very excited about this experience.
- I guess pasties are
like a thing you wear
when you don't want to wear clothes,
but it's illegal to show your nipples.
- Just from like how curved this is,
I don't know if it's going to be able
to reach my nipple.
- Well, when I agreed to do
this, I thought it was pastries,
so I actually thought I was
going to be eating stuff.
So now I'm kind of more nervous.
- I'm really excited
about this experience,
let's get my nips ready.
- Supposed to put glue around the outside,
but not in the center,
so that I don't rip off my nipple.
- Now, I do have a third nipple,
so do I need, like, three?
- I have to take some of this,
and then tease myself a little bit
by putting it on my nipple.
- Have there been any like,
emergency room reports
of how often people accidentally
rip off their nipples
with pasties?
Because if you use the wrong glue...
- I've never been a guy who
really touches his nipples
a lot but my hands are just like...
(laughter)
- Those like little hats
samurais would wear?
- And then...
- I kind of like, just like the one.
It's got like a nice pirate feel.
- I can barely articulate words
because that's how
embarrassed I am right now.
- I don't really feel
like this does a great job
of covering up the nipples.
If anything, it just draws
attention to the nipples.
- I mean, I would use this.
I feel like, this is kind
of like to feel safer.
- What's so terrible about a nipple?
They're kind of weird looking,
but everybody's got 'em.
- You just got drop it, right?
And then you gotta like...
Hi, Mom.
- I'm not dancing.
- I think it's weird that
there's such a taboo against
freely shown nipples,
that we had to invent
a device specifically
designed to be glued on them
to cover them.
- I feel sexy, like I can
move, I can move around.
- If you let guys show their nipples,
then how come you don't let
girls show their nipples?
- I want to celebrate my chest area,
but as far as covering up,
or feeling ashamed of it,
this does not help at all.
(playful music)